today's topic do white people have cun
culture
okay so when people say black culture
you have to understand what that means
black culture does not mean the
amalgamation of all black people
you know black culture represents a
specific
set of people who live in america who
are black whose only
form of identification with people who
understand each other
from a certain like struggle or cultural
standpoint
are other blacks and so they use the
term
black to identify as a group right
why people in america view themselves as
american
black folks in america either view
themselves as black or african american
there's a suffix to
represent their blackness so i think
that's why people talk about black
culture and then the counterpart is like
well why people got culture too yeah but
you don't really refer as
white cause you refer to it as american
culture
or different sub genre of cultures that
you have yeah there's
american culture that's why but if you
talk about the world itself
there's no white culture there's white
cultures you see if you think my people
are scottish
they're white and they have their own
scottish
culture try to mix
scottish with irish they have their
separate cultures you can't do that
try to mix scottish irish
and english and call it the same
you're in for a fight let me talk about
a fight you're in for a great movie
braveheart russians
then again it depends what russians
where they're from you know what i mean
i think the only idea of blackness
like or whiteness the only place where
that's kind of pervasive
is in culture cultures or countries
where multiculturalism
is very prominent in that
people who are from minor minor minority
communities feel ostracized by the
greater culture
so like in some countries because you
feel so ostracized for either the color
of your skin
or your background or whatever it might
be
you're going to identify with something
other than the country which you live in
right and so for black folks that wasn't
like you know you live through
segregation
you're not going to proudly call
yourself an american like the other
white folks because they don't see you
as equals
so you find a different moniker so you
say now we're black people
right so it's a bit of a difference in
that regard and we have that black
culture that stems from the same
yeah the same things that we went
through but
right then you go to africa it's a
different story we don't
identify ourselves as black people we
identify ourselves by our tribe
even i'm from ethiopia it matters which
part of the country
are you oromo are you so then there's
all these different like vine factions
but it's never on the basis of
race per se on so many different things
so
when you talk about whiteness or black
black black people or you talk about
this that it's just tribalism i think
oftentimes when you hear like black
folks saying that to white people it
almost sounds like pejoratively
you guys have no culture which i mean on
the face of it's ridiculous you know
whether you go from italians to
spanish people to ukrainians like the
cuisine is different the language
is different the traditions everything
like of course
you know if you're talking about a
person with a white complexion having
culture there's
various forms but they just don't
identify them with race the thing is
americans are sometimes so enclosed in
their bubble that is america yeah that
they fail to realize that white folks
are drastically different
in different places even like oh my god
white people can't spice their food go
to italy and try to tell them that they
don't know how to spice their food
i'm gonna tell you you're gonna eat
their food you black okay i take that
back
right so it really is um
a bit of a closed-minded perspective one
and two
it is a very american-centric uh
perspective
i don't think americans realize i'm not
saying that to this you guys but you
guys don't realize
how self-centered you are
you guys don't realize how there's more
to the world than you it's like just
just
we went back to this subject like just
like racism some americans really think
that racism just exists in
in usa they they they deny
the experience of other people and
there's other things going on even
within your country
there's different things that are going
on except your experience yeah that's
why it's so hard sometimes to speak
about them with americans or with
people from the continents of america
it's hard to speak because they have
their own
relationship with what they live and
everything and stuff and they they
cannot
they cannot get outside that box when
you think that no that's where we lived
most americans don't know what pizza is
no
yeah well they don't know pizza pizza no
they don't know pizza pizza they don't
know
that's not no what they know is that new
york pizza and it's like
it's just spaghetti just just give you
something all right
spaghetti meatballs
is not italian
do you know canadians don't live in
eagles you know what i mean like
to be fair it's not really their fault
that's part education part like
america exports culture they don't
import traditionally
or if they do it's tex-mex it's not
mexican yes this is right so
there's always that knee i love me some
mexicans i love me some mac mexican
right what do you like taco bell i'm
like oh
right oh you don't put cheese in your
tacos okay
chill americans don't watch movies with
subtitles they take your movie
cast kevin hart in it and then put on an
english speaker
actors that's all they do right so so
that's the way
that's the way it's not totally their
fault but i think that's where a lot of
these ideas come from
the ball is already rolling so that like
there's like americans are stepping on
the american ball
yes and they're going down the hill yeah
and
they got momentum so just they're just
keeping up with it and it's just going
down it's not yet
like you said it's not completely
revolving yeah and another topic is like
why
why don't other minorities do what black
americans do like our mexican one
because black americans specifically
don't have
um a root country to tie themselves to
to be more tribal
no if you ask most latinos who live out
in the states
they're very tribalistic based off of
what part of latin america you're from
you know
if you're bolivian or if you're mexican
if you're from colombia
or if you're from peru it's a different
city just within
mexico the northeast
with the people from around you know
what i mean it could be a problem
because it's a different
within the same country yeah so even
though you may view asians as a whole
ensemble
let me tell you asians right they vary
chinese japanese korean it's a different
vlogging thailand
they have a richness that they can tie
themselves to to be more tribalistic and
so
people yellow people
it's not the way it works it's a
different history it's a different
experience so
i think that's why there's that thing
with blackness specifically and i think
the last thing i want to bring up is
like some people
ask like why do you feel the need to tie
yourself to a culture or anything and i
think the main thing is
people just want to belong people want
to feel like they fit in
and sometimes when you live in a country
that you are not the majority
it feels very difficult to feel like
you're supposed to be there
so you try to find groups to identify
yourself with whether it's and you can
find out even on like a
microscopic level like if you even take
like school
you're going to a new school you're just
trying to find a group that you fit in
with
within the song people like why don't
you just be a loner it's like it doesn't
work that well you can't but i mean it's
not most people
you know i mean that's you got
fraternities and sororities yeah
wait a minute you're gonna tell me that
you went to college
you put the blazer of an animal that you
probably fear
go gators uh your your whole semester
but you can't understand how belonging
feels like
really yeah you know it's also one of
those things like
i don't even think it was that important
either until i went to brazil one year
and then i was walking through the
streets and like nobody stared at me
whenever when i went to neighborhood
like
everyone just assumed i was brazilian
because apparently i kind of fit in in
some ways
because everyone looks kind of brazilian
yeah exactly there's a there's a palette
of beat there's like
yeah yeah look at the the the fact that
spectrum it's like going to coop cuba
yeah you're white you could be cuban
you're black you could be cuban
so so there's that feeling of like oh i
can just relax a little bit more
because i'm not just looked at because
like oh my god i want to touch your hair
or
oh my god uh i don't want you to be my
daughter he's like oh you stepped inside
a
store depending on what kind of store
you're going with you know people are
not going to look at you if you're going
i mean so i just think there's that
feeling of just relax that you feel
when you're in a group or an environment
where you feel at home
it's all it's just a sense of belonging
it's a home that's all it is so i think
that's why people always want to be tied
to something and it can be tough
when you're far away from your homeland
or anything that you can really feel
like that
it's difficult so for people who don't
understand it
you might get that opportunity when you
live in a country where you're the
minority and you don't always get
treated the best in some situation
especially like for white people
whenever they go whenever they go to
countries that people are white
and but the white people can still know
they can still look at you and know that
you're different
just by looking at you you go to russia
and you're american you're white they're
gonna know
they're gonna know you're gonna feel
some type of way if you hear
god damn i can't have no service here
and you're like oh
another american in russia you're gonna
feel something something's gonna be
close to home it's gonna
that's the feeling and you not having
well i don't feel like i'm belonging
i don't need to belong that's a
privilege because you don't need that
because everywhere you go
no it kind of fits it's not it's not you
want to tell me why
because when i used to live in ethiopia
i can assure you the white people band
with the white people
i know they eat at the same tables they
get the same restaurants and they hang
out with each other
why it's not we were saying it's not my
whole point is like it's not their
policy even when they go to other
countries they also try to form that's
what i'm saying
that's what i'm saying yeah that's
exactly what i said you go to russia and
you
you're you've been there for a couple of
days a couple of weeks and then you just
try to speak russian okay and then you
hear an american you're gonna be like
oh sh where you from dude i'm from
wisconsin
well i'm from new york but what's up
yeah you know you're right you're right
what i'm in yeah you're right
so yeah i get where you guys are coming
from and some of you might be annoyed by
it but
it's really not as big as it really
seems it's just
yeah that's what it is so hopefully this
video was interesting for you guys and
you enjoyed it
if you did leave a comment below do all
that good stuff and that's pretty much
it
[Music]
foreign